what could be better than this there's
plenty of snow and weather conditions
are good but everything's so expensive
here in Arosa a traditional ski resort
in the heart of Switzerland since the
swiss franc started to soar costs for
eurozone visitors have skyrocketed
refreshments off peace cost 20 percent
more now it's got to the point where you
think should I have another drink or not
and if you do decide to have a drink
then this beer for example will set you
back almost six euros a euro more than
two weeks ago visitors are having to cut
down elsewhere we changed our plans and
decided to walk up because the half-day
ski pass is really expensive it costs 58
francs for four hours from noon to four
that's a lot hoteliers are afraid guests
will stay away like tommy Blatter owner
of this four star hotel the Blatter's
have already received cancellations
they've just received an email from
someone in Germany he worked it out and
said look the cost of staying at your
hotel has gone up 15% since last
Thursday that's the equivalent of 800
euros in 10 days that's a lot of money
so now we have to do our bits or
visitors will be happy that includes
offering things like a free ski school
for children hoteliers and vacation
apartment owners in neurosis started
paying for that three years ago when the
swiss franc was strong it costs them
eight hundred thousand francs a season
the children don't just go to school for
a year but up to seven years their
parents also come for seven years the
resort is having to come up with more
attractions events like the unofficial
World Cup in snow football in the town
centre weren't specifically mentioned
anywhere in the
now the head of tourism promotes them on
his homepage
he's already noticed at drop-off in
interest
I'd say we're receiving 25 maybe even
40% fewer inquiries and this is our high
season we left to do something to make
sure the second half of our winter
season in March and April is a success
week you can fall back you stalled me
the slopes above arosa
are quiet now the last skiers are on
their way back down to the valley so do
they plan to come back next year if the
prices don't drastically rise again
because of the new exchange rate we'll
definitely come back but we have changed
our behavior are there alternatives yes
Austria France Italy they also have ski
regions the same mountains same snow
like a common guys and Smith and they're
definitely a bit cheaper but locals
insist that nowhere is quite as
beautiful as here in our OSA